Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Elvira Pavlenko : Le 24 février 2022,
7 heures 30, Kharkiv, Ukraine.
Le matin, je dois aller
à la réunion pour le travail.
Je suis responsable d’un magasin
de vêtements sportifs.
Mais je me réveille plus tôt
que d’habitude,
à cause de coups de fil des parents
de mon ex-copain qui s’appelle Dima.
Ils me disent que la guerre a commencé.
Il faut être prêt pour partir.
Je pense que c’est une blague
car nous n’avons pas entendu de bruit.
J'ouvre la fenêtre.
J’entends le bruit de tirs d’artillerie.
J'allume la télé pour regarder les infos
et c'est vraiment la guerre.
On sort, on essaye de retirer du cash.
Impossible.
On achète de l'eau et de la nourriture.
On passe toute la journée
jusqu’au lendemain dans le métro
car c’est l’endroit le plus sûr.
Mais l’ambiance est terrible
dans le métro.
Il fait froid : -15 °C.
On entend le bruit des bombardements.
Les enfants pleurent,
les chiens gémissent de peur.
Parfois les rats courent.
Je refuse de partir
car c’est ma ville natale
où il y a ma famille,
mes amis, mon logement
et je pense
qu’il n’y en a pas pour longtemps.
Maxime Dheilly : Amiens,
quartier de la Hotoie.
Il fait beau.
Un froid sec s'habille sous un ciel bleu.
C’est le temps idéal pour
un nouveau départ, une nouvelle vie.
J'ai 32 ans.
Je suis professeur de philosophie
et je décide de prendre une année
pour voyager en Europe.
La Grèce me tend les bras.
Les Cyclades avec leurs eaux turquoise
et le sable clair.
Avant de préparer
mon sac de globe-trotter,
un petit dèj s’impose.
En bon Français : café noir et BFM.
(Rires)
La télévision crie.
Le monde n’est pas du tout aligné
sur mes rêves naïfs de jeune occidental.
L’horreur est à l’est
et elle vient de frapper à ma porte.
C’est où, Kharkiv ?
Odessa ?
Marioupol ?
Je regarde sur la carte.
La guerre en Ukraine vient de commencer.
Quelle horreur !
Mais quelle horreur d’imaginer
ces enfants sous les bombes !
Quel non-sens aussi !
L’impuissance face au non-sens
me pousse à agir.
Même si je n’ai pas d’asso,
pas vraiment de moyens,
j’ai envie de faire quelque chose.
Changement de programme, donc.
Partir le plus vite possible
à la frontière ukrainienne
avec un camion chargé
de médicaments, de vêtements,
enfin tout ce qu’on trouvera
dans le réseau amiénois.
Toquer aux portes des pharmacies,
demander à la Croix-Rouge
et trouver un fourgon
avec un chauffeur au plus vite.
EP : Le 2 mars 2022 Kharkiv, Ukraine.
La situation n'a fait qu'empirer.
Il y a la pénurie d’eau, de nourriture,
des médicaments dans les magasins.
Je suis dans la file d’attente
pendant 2 heures pour acheter de l’eau.
Deux avions ennemis survolent et lancent
leurs roquettes juste à côté de chez moi.
Et c’est à ce moment, je trouve
le premier sens à ce chaos : survivre.
Et je décide de quitter ma ville natale.
MD : Allo Adrien ?
Oui, c’est Max, ça va depuis le temps ?
Ouais, as-tu toujours
ton fourgon aménagé ?
Ok, alors tu vas peut-être
me prendre pour un dingue,
mais ça te dirait de partir
à la frontière ukrainienne
avec ton fourgon chargé
de produits de première nécessité
pour aider les Ukrainiens
qui fuient la guerre ?
Et il me répond oui tout de suite.
Pour le moment, on n’a pas grand-chose.
On a quelques vêtements pour bébé,
des couvertures, pas mal de dentifrice.
Mais c’était sans compter sur Adrien
qui trouve auprès d’une asso
une quinzaine de cartons de médicaments.
On est rempli à ras bord.
EP : Le 3 mars 2022,
gare du Sud de Kharkiv.
Le temps d’attente pour le train
sans destination ni horaire connu
est de trois ou quatre heures, ou plus.
Sur cette photo,
il peut sembler que ce sont des années
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Il y a beaucoup de réfugiés.
Les armées et les policiers sont partout,
la menace d’attaque aérienne,
la peur et le désespoir.
Cet interminable moment de fuir les bombes
nous a été volé par les avions ennemis
qui ont lancé des roquettes
juste à côté de chez nous,
sur le bâtiment d’hôtel de ville central.
Je pense que c'est la fin.
Mais on a réussi à prendre le train
à la deuxième tentative.
À quel point la vie
nous paraît alors précieuse
et à quel point chaque minute de notre vie
nous paraît très importante.
Le train nous amène
vers la région de Dniepr.
MD : Je prépare mes caméras, je me dis
qu’on va filmer notre aventure,
même si pour le moment, je ne sais pas
trop où on va livrer notre cargaison,
ni exactement où on va dormir.
Tout ce que je sais, c'est qu'on va au
nord de la Pologne, près de la frontière,
à Lublin, à 1600 kilomètres d'ici.
Avec Adrien, on organise une petite
cagnotte pour payer l’essence et le péage
et puis let's go vers l'inconnu.
On garde simplement en tête ces images
d'enfants qui fuient les bombes.
Nous, notre manière à nous
de donner un peu de sens,
eh bien, c’est cette mission
humanitaire qu’on improvise.
EP : Le 11 mars 2022, région de Dniepr.
Cela fait maintenant huit jours
que nous habitons dans la famille
du frère de Dima.
Mais à cause du terrible conflit
dans leur famille,
car la guerre, elle, a créé
les tensions entre nous
et en plus la menace aérienne
dans notre région,
nous décidons de partir vers l’ouest.
Les deux hommes qui nous emmènent
vers la gare, ce sont des policiers.
Ce sont des proches de la famille
du frère de Dima.
Je pense être en sécurité.
En fait, la guerre semble
les avoir déshumanisés.
Ils prennent beaucoup d'argent
pour le transport.
Pas de solidarité ici.
Ils sont très agressifs
pendant tout le voyage.
Un des deux policiers me dit : (Ukrainien)
«Ce jour,
c’est le dernier jour de ta vie.»
Quand deux policiers
se transforment en criminels,
plus rien n’a de sens.
Ils menacent de me violer et de me tuer.
Les deux menacent Dima de le mobiliser
immédiatement pour la guerre.
Au milieu de nulle part,
car je ne savais pas où on est,
j’écris un message
à ma meilleure pote où je dis :
«Si dans deux heures,
tu n’as pas de nouvelles de ma part,
cela signifie que je suis morte.»
Je perds connaissance à cause de la peur
et je me réveille
à la périphérie de Dniepr.
Ils ont jeté nos valises.
Heureusement, on les récupère.
C’est ainsi que les personnes qui peuvent
sembler les plus fiables peuvent changer.
Et donc je perds
toutes mes raisons d’avancer.
Mais heureusement, mes amis
m’aident à me relever de cet enfer
et je me raccroche alors à une seule
chose qui a encore du sens : ma mère,
pour qui je dois combattre
cette cruelle réalité
et mes proches qui sont décédés
avant la guerre
mais qui auraient voulu que je sois
heureuse malgré tout dans cette vie,
notamment mes grands-parents.
À défaut des vivants,
on s’accroche à ses souvenirs.
MD : On part le 9 mars.
Et sur la route, je réussis à trouver
l’hébergement via l’appli Couchsurfing
chez une Polonaise qui parle français.
Elle est traductrice et en plus elle
héberge une famille ukrainienne.
On arrive tard
et on est accueillis par Tania, la maman
et Roman, son fils de treize ans,
qui nous offre chaleureusement
notre premier hymne ukrainien.
(Chantant) Ma la la la li la li la
Ce moment contraste beaucoup
avec l’ambiance tendue
qu’on a rencontrée
en arrivant dans la ville,
avec tous ces convois
militaires et humanitaires
qui s’enfoncent vers la frontière.
Le lendemain, on fait
la connaissance de Victoria,
alias Vika,
si solaire pour une jeune fille
de douze ans qui fuit la guerre.
Voilà.
Toute l'équipe est prête à aller livrer
notre cargaison au camion ukrainien.
EP : Le 12 mars 2022,
gare centrale de Dniepr.
Pas le temps de se remettre
de nos émotions.
Nous partons vers l’ouest,
pendant 28 h en dormant
par terre dans le wagon sombre.
Pas de lumière pour que l’ennemi
ne remarque pas la progression des trains
en traversant les montagnes
et avec la menace aérienne
juste à côté de notre train.
Nous traversons les Carpates.
En essayant de trouver un endroit
où il n’y a pas de bombardement,
j’admire notre nature.
Qui peut vraiment détruire
cet endroit pittoresque ?
Et pour quelle raison et quel sens
nous pouvons donner à tout cela ?
Je regarde les détails du tableau
qui défile sous mes yeux.
La petite maison au loin.
La cheminée fumante.
La neige.
Apparemment, les gens ne voient
pas l’intérêt de profiter du silence.
Mais quand on est sous les bombes
avec des sirènes,
le silence est un cri paisible.
Et même si on n’aime pas le silence,
il vaut bien mieux profiter
du chant des oiseaux
que le bruit des oiseaux
de fer du Kremlin.
MD : Le 12 mars, nous voilà
au milieu d’associations
avec des gens qui s’agitent
dans tous les sens
pour livrer les camions ukrainiens
au plus vite.
Comme dans notre stock,
on a des médicaments rares,
de l’insuline notamment,
on devient prioritaire et on vide
toute notre cargaison en une journée.
Mission accomplie.
Toute l’équipe se congratule.
Avec Adrien, on lâche
notre premier : Slava Ukraini !
La soirée est un moment joli, inoubliable.
On danse, on chante, on fait des tours
de magie avec les enfants.
Et c’est étrange parce que
la guerre est en toile de fond
et on y répond par
des rires et des sourires.
On devait rester deux jours.
Voilà qu’on s’engage dans
une aventure d’une semaine.
On va continuer à aider les réfugiés
qui arrivent à Lublin.
Et dans ce quotidien qui s’organise,
eh bien, on apprend à communiquer
sans langage,
on se prend dans les bras
quand ça ne va pas.
On fait de la musique, des ateliers
d’origami avec les enfants,
des chasses au trésor.
C’est comme si on devenait
une seule et même famille
avec cette famille ukrainienne,
mais dans un espace-temps qui
n’a pas vraiment de repère sur Terre.
On sait aussi qu’à tous
les sourires de Vika,
un ennemi pas loin répond
par des bombes et des charniers.
La dernière nuit,
Roman semble faire une crise d’angoisse.
Il fait les cent pas dans le couloir,
criant qu’il veut rentrer chez lui.
Alors avec Adrien,
on sort notre guitare de voyage
et on se met à lui apprendre
quelques accords.
Ça a l'air de le calmer.
D’ailleurs, le lendemain, avec la famille,
on décide tous ensemble d’écrire
une chanson franco-ukrainienne.
Ça, c'est un joli moment.
Et puis c'est déjà l'heure pour nous,
le temps de repartir.
Je me souviens que Victoria
nous lâche en ukrainien :
«On se revoit en France.»
Et puis on décide d’offrir
ma guitare à Roman.
EP : Le 18 avril 2002, Lviv, Ukraine.
Cela fait maintenant un mois
que Dima et moi,
nous habitons dans l’auberge de jeunesse.
Nous travaillons dans le magasin de sport.
Et c’est à ce moment que je rencontre
dans ce magasin deux militaires français
qui me disent qu’il faut
déménager en France,
car là-bas, on peut vivre tranquillement.
Les ennemis bombardent Lviv
et je décide de partir toute seule
car Dima me suggère
que c’est mieux pour moi
et lui, il n’a pas le droit
de quitter le pays.
Les bénévoles français m’aident
à traverser la frontière polonaise
et me déposent à Arras, en France,
où ma première famille d’accueil
m’attendait.
MD : Voilà un mois qu’on est rentré.
Et à notre plus grande surprise,
effectivement,
la famille ukrainienne
décide de venir en France.
Alors, je leur laisse mon appartement,
le temps qu’ils puissent
trouver une situation stable.
Et puis moi, j’ai changé,
je me suis même réinventé.
J’ai décidé au quotidien d’aider
les Ukrainiennes et Ukrainiens
qui arrivent à Amiens en leur trouvant
un logement, un travail,
en les aidant dans
les démarches administratives.
Et d’ailleurs, maintenant,
Tania travaille au CHU
et les enfants vont au collège Sagebien.
EP : Le 25 juin 2022,
la France.
J’habite dans une petite ville,
chez la deuxième famille
d’accueil, très gentille.
Mais en réfléchissant à comment
penser mon avenir d’exilée,
je décide d’écrire un post sur Facebook
où je demande s’il est possible
de me trouver un travail
ou de rejoindre une université.
MD : Je reçois sur un groupe Facebook
un message d’une Ukrainienne
qui cherche une université
dans le nord de la France.
Je réponds que je peux l’aider.
Et j’organise une rencontre à Amiens
avec Tania, Vika et Roman,
afin qu’elle découvre la ville
et qu’elle soit en confiance.
C'est Elvira.
Et elle choisit Amiens pour penser
son avenir en France.
EP : Le 25 juillet 2022, Amiens, France.
Maxime et moi, on est sur le banc,
à côté des hortillonnages
sur le chemin qui mène
à Dreuil-lès-Amiens.
Je suis depuis une semaine à Amiens
pour poursuivre mes études.
C’est grâce à Maxime.
Et en plus me laisser son appartement,
il fait son documentaire
sur les Ukrainiennes en exil.
C’est à ce moment-là
que je lui raconte mon histoire.
Je respire un peu mieux dans cette quête
permanente de vouloir donner du sens.
MD : Elvira me raconte
son histoire, justement.
Et j'ai l'impression que le deuxième
épisode de mon aventure commence.
Il ne s'agit plus simplement
d'une mission humanitaire.
Mais une véritable rencontre humaine.
Je pleure.
Je pleure quand elle me raconte son récit.
Et c’est étrange parce que c’est
comme si les rôles étaient inversés.
C'est elle qui est victime.
Et c’est elle qui me rassure
quand moi je pleure.
Drôle de sens
à cette existence parfois si absurde.
Mais grâce à Elvira, Tania, Vika,
Roman et Adrien,
j’ai pu donner un nouveau sens à ma vie.
Voilà que ceux qui fuient la guerre
m’ont fait comprendre
qu’il ne faut pas attendre de la vie
qu’elle nous apporte
des réponses à nos questions.
Il faut plutôt saisir, se confronter
au sens et le construire soi-même.
Même lorsque tout semble perdu.
EP : Avec Maxime,
on est devenu amis et complices,
et nous avons tout fait pour mettre
ma maman à l’abri en France.
Et maintenant en vivant l’instant
présent avec vous sur cette scène,
je comprends que tout ce que
nous vivons a du sens.
Au prix de l’horreur peut-être,
on apprend beaucoup.
La guerre et l’exil m’ont
complètement changée.
Je peux sortir de l’enfer
et maintenant je suis complètement
une autre personne.
Je trouve du sens en aidant mon peuple.
J’appelle régulièrement mes proches
qui sont restés en Ukraine.
Souvent, ils sont plongés
dans le noir, sans eau courante.
Souvent, ils me disent que
la situation est compliquée.
Mon expérience me permet de comprendre
ce que c'est de survivre.
Comment s’adapter dans un nouveau pays ?
Comment s’intégrer dans un nouveau pays ?
Je comprends que l’essentiel dans la vie,
c’est de pouvoir changer
son point de vue sur les choses.
Dans les situations terribles,
essayons de donner du sens.
C’est ce que je veux transmettre
à tous les personnes victimes
de la violence humaine.
MD : J’avais un boulot.
Je n’en ai plus.
Je rêvais de sable fin.
Eh bien, j’ai roulé sur 3 600 kilomètres
d’asphalte enneigé.
J'étais plutôt pessimiste, avec un goût
amer pour les affaires humaines.
Je suis optimiste.
J’avais aussi un syndrome d’imposteur :
mais au nom de quoi
j’allais aider les Ukrainiens ?
Eh bien, ce soir, je suis assez fier
de vous partager
ma petite victoire personnelle.
J’ai aidé comme j’ai pu,
j’ai donné tout ce que je pouvais,
mais ce n’est rien en comparaison
de tout ce que j’ai reçu.
Elvira
a fui la mort pour vivre.
Moi, j’ai voulu me confronter
à la mort pour me sentir vivant.
Alors ce soir, on voulait vous
offrir un petit cadeau -
grand cadeau.
On est fiers de vous dire ensemble :
(Ensemble) : La vie est belle.
(Applaudissements)
Adrien (Chante)
J’ai vu brûler, brûler la terre.
Je savais pas qu'on pouvait s'y faire.
Il a foulé, foulé vos terres,
le colosse aux jambes de pierre.
Dites-moi, dites-moi que l’histoire
ne peut jamais perdre la mémoire.
Des larmes et des roses trémières,
couleront les rivières.
EP. MD et A : Oh ooooh
EP, MD et A : Oh ooooh
EP : (Chante en ukrainien)
Il est fait de vastes champs,
il est fait de terres riches,
Ce pays qui est le mien.
Mon Ukraine.
Mais un grand malheur est venu chez nous.
En apportant son lot de souffrance,
de tristesse, de douleur.
MD (en chantant) :
Si des roses pouvaient chanter.
c’est à Vika qu’elles feraient songer.
Et si mes rêves sont en fleurs ce matin,
C’est que la vie lui va si bien.
Le sourire de Roman se lève
et nos deux cœurs se soulèvent,
en donnant du sens à l’horreur,
c’est une nouvelle aurore.
EP, MD et A :
Oh ohoh
(Applaudissements)